[Musica]
sono qui oggi a parlare di arte in
effetti perché perché in realtà l'arte
da sempre si è interessata delle forme
di innovazione sociale e tecnologica
l'arte la tecnologia cambiano insieme
agli artisti vogliono indagare e
scoprire le novità nel mondo della
tecnologia
quindi è solo normale che gli artisti
stiano guardando a questa novità che
sono gli nfp
mai nel mondo della storia dell'arte
neanche con la nascita dell'arte
concettuale
c'è stata una polarizzazione di opinioni
il mondo dell'arte si divide in quelli
che considerano gli effetti la più
grande bolla speculativa mai esistita
paragonandola alla bolla dei tulipani
quando in olanda nel seicento i bulbi
arrivarono a prezzi incredibili e in
pochi mesi scesero a picco così come una
parte di mondo dell'arte che invece
considera gli nfp una rivoluzione
veramente una possibilità futurista per
il mondo dell'arte di riscrivere tutte
le regole e di entrare davvero nel
secolo futuro e quindi bisogna un attimo
porsi il problema di cosa sta succedendo
hanno ragione dei trattori o hanno
ragione i sostenitori in realtà forse
nessuno dei due in modo così assoluto
quello che stupisce questa fretta di
avere un opinione sugli effetti quando
gli nfp in qualche modo sono un fenomeno
veramente nuovo in questo mondo è vero
già dal 2017 gli effetti venivano usati
e creati ma non nel mondo dell'arte
invece nel 2021 improvvisamente il mondo
dell'arte si è fermato e ha dovuto
prendere in considerazione questo nuovo
media espressivo perché perché l'opera
di bper every day for five stars and
bass quindi tutti i giorni primi
cinquemila giorni è stata battuta
all'asta da christie's per 69 milioni di
dollari 69 milioni di dollari beh un
attimo in realtà erano 69 milioni di
dollari in etere home che non è proprio
la stessa cosa ovviamente questo fatto
il fatto che un'opera d'arte digitale
raggiungesse il terzo prezzo più alto
mai pagato di un'opera di un artista
vivente affermato il mondo dell'arte ha
raggiunto le prime pagine di tutti i
giornali
e a posto tutti davanti a questo
interrogativo di cosa sarebbe successo
nel mondo dell'arte ma un passo indietro
cosa sono questi nf tvn effetti sono in
realtà un
una stringa di file su cui viene
registrata associata a qualcosa che
esiste nel mondo digitale
inizialmente gli nfp erano delle
immagini delle applicazioni degli
adesivi delle possibilità di acquisire
asset digitali nei videogiochi e
inizialmente i designer giocavano con
questa tecnologia per vendere le loro
opere i più importanti iniziali
esperimenti di questo mondo sono state
in realtà nel 2017
dei giochi nati con questa tecnologia
pensiamo a sé l'arva l'ubs che hanno
prodotto i cripto punk cripto punk che
erano delle piccole testine 10 mila di
queste figure tutte ritratta di profilo
tutte con lo stesso numero di pixel e
questo algoritmo continuava a cambiarle
i primi addirittura sono stati
distribuiti gratuitamente
adesso sono passati alle aste in gruppi
di tre fino a 17 milioni di dollari
oppure cripto kittens insomma lo
sappiamo tutti che quando metti un
gattino sui social i tuoi follower
salgono in maniera esponenziale dei
gattini digitali che venivano accoppiati
sposati ne vengono prodotti 22 mila per
un incasso totale in questi scambi di 3
milioni di euro quindi non possiamo dire
che in realtà questo mercato non
esistesse prima di pippe meyer un
mercato che si stima avesse
la misura di circa un milione di dollari
ecco dopo l'asta di questo mercato in
meno di un anno è arrivato un bilione di
dollari e quindi c'è stata una
trasformazione
cosa è successo quindi nel marzo 20 21
un'opera digitale mentata quindi in
qualche modo creata è associata tramite
la block chain a un immagine è stata
venduta per una somma sorprendente ma
facciamo un passo indietro quindi
quest'opera in realtà non è stata
venduta l'opera è stata venduto il
certificato di file qui tn effetti sono
a tutti gli effetti una sorta di
certificato di autenticità che rendono
uniche riconoscibili le opere d'arte e
per mister e vivono su la block chain
questa block chain e un una rete
decentralizzata in cui ogni tassello
garantisce l'autenticità e la non
deperibilità delle singole parti quindi
per capire un po in qualche modo cosa
succede come se tu compri un biglietto
di un concerto e il biglietto del
concerto è uguale al biglietto del tuo
amico però la block cei nel tuo
biglietto registra chi l'ha comprato che
posto è dove l'hai comprato perché l'hai
comprato i dati registrati sulla black
jail non possono essere modificati tu
puoi aggiungere un mattone a questa
questa serie di transazioni ma non puoi
modificare quelle prima da una parte
questa diciamo questa rete in cui tutti
gli utenti sanno la verità
rende il consumo di dati e di energia un
vero problema ecologico dall'altra rende
autenticata in maniera assoluta
qualsiasi informazione senza bisogno di
un organo centrale che la utente di
quelli in qualche modo quando questi
collezionisti hanno comprato da
christie's in etere un questo mft loro
hanno comprato
l'autentica di questo lavoro infatti il
lavoro stesso
non è registrato sulla block chain ma
vive su un'altra piattaforma digitale e
su etere un vive solo lo smart contract
questo contratto associato a questo n
effetti e quindi torniamo un po il
paradosso un paradosso per i due mondi
che si incontrano in questo caso da una
parte nel mondo digitale diciamo le cose
nascono per essere riprodotte in maniera
unica e scambiata e quindi il fatto che
questo mondo scelga di rendere unica e
diciamo preziosa e rara
un'immagine digitale contraddice un po
tutti i presupposti di questo mondo
legato alla rete dall'altra i
collezionisti comprano e pagano molto
delle opere rare uniche
ecco qui è molto strano perché l'opera
vive sui canali digitali chiunque può
scaricarsi in alta definizione questi
questo collage delle 5.000 in realtà i 5
mila erano cinquemila post sui social
uno al giorno fatti dhabi pole per 5.000
giorni ma
i diritti restano a people quindi in
qualche modo il collezionista ha
comprato l'idea di bper perché così
scandalosa questa cosa dove si
incontrano questi due mondi il mondo
dell'arte perché è così scioccato da
questo fatto in realtà se uno va a
vedere la storia dell'arte non dovrebbe
essere così strano con la nascita
dell'arte concettuale
in realtà abbiamo sdoganato il fatto che
un'opera d'arte sia l'idea che ci sta
dietro se pensiamo a un artista
collezionato in tutti i più importanti
musei del mondo come se lewis su hewitt
vendeva questi suoi wall drawing che
hanno raggiunto prezzi molto importanti
in realtà vendendo un certificato un
certificato che non era né nient'altro
che le istruzioni che venivano date a
una persona che su la suddetta parete
doveva portare a termine questo suo wall
drawing che di solito aveva delle
istruzioni molto meccaniche non molto
creative e se il collezionista cambiava
casa dopo che aveva creato il wall
drawing beh non era un problema doveva
imbiancare la parete precedente nella
casa nuova sempre seguendo le istruzioni
poteva ricreare wall drawing tino sehgal
un grande artista tedesco più giovane
che ha rappresentato la germania alla
biennale di venezia fa delle opere che
sono delle performance delle performance
dove succedono delle azioni che lui non
documenta né in video né in foto e che
addirittura obbliga i collezionisti a
comprare dal notaio con un atto orale
quindi lui non va neanche un certificato
quindi in qualche modo questo questa
idea del mondo dell'arte che vuole
mettere in discussione la q
modificazione dell'arte il fatto che
l'arte sia un bene di scambio si è
spinta molto avanti
tino sehgal ha obbligati collezionisti a
comprare formalmente niente addirittura
questo contratto li vincola delle regole
quando presentano il lavoro a pagare il
minimo sindacale di performer a farlo
vedere in qualche modo quindi forse
questo lato rivoluzionario di pagare
un'idea legata un n effetti una cifra
importante non è così nuovo e scandalosa
per il mondo dell'arte e allora perché
il mondo dell'arte si è scandalizzato
perché in realtà fino a una settimana
prima a nessuno nel mondo dell'arte
sapeva che fosse people people era un
designer noto nel mondo dei social ma
non era una personalità e i suoi
acquirenti due grandi investitori in
cripto valute non erano collezionisti
quindi forse quello che ha scandalizzato
il mondo dell'arte al di là delle
articoli del mondo dell'arte in cui si
lamenta il consumo e la non
sostenibilità della blog c'è il vero
maxi sicuramente la tecnologia andrà in
qualche modo a rimediare e il fatto che
sia saltato il mondo dell'arte cioè che
questa transazione di un'opera una cifra
mai vista non ha avuto bisogno dei
player del mondo dell'arte ha fatto
fuori quelli che vengono considerati i
gatekeeper del mondo dell'arte e in
qualche modo reso la domanda e l'offerta
le regole con cui veniva scambiata a
quest'opera l'acqua si pongono però
degli altri problemi
un'opera d'arte è importante perché
qualcuno è pronto a pagarla una cifra
molto alta o è importante perché dice
qualcosa di cruciale sul mondo in cui
viviamo sulla società beh la storia
dell'arte forse ormai ci ha insegnato
che il prezzo non può essere l'unico
parametro per giudicare l'importanza di
un'opera in fondo grandi artisti come
van gogh sono morti in povertà e dei
loro coetani venivano comprati a cifre
importanti e nella strada e l'arte non
hanno lasciato niente quindi in qualche
modo però questo tema diciamo questo
conflitto tra un'opera vale quello che
qualcuno è pronta a pagarla un'opera
vale quello che qualcuno dice che vale
in un sistema è un po irrisolto nel
mondo dell'arte ecco con questo mondo
degli nfp
quello che è successo è che il mondo
dell'arte passato nell'era della
disintermediazione
non è stato importante quello che ha
detto nessun curatore critico direttore
di museo gallerista per decidere che
quest'opera valeva molto e è stato solo
il desiderio di degli acquirenti di
sceglierla a renderlo importante qui
però bisogna fare ancora un altro
piccolo passo indietro perché vedendola
così sembra dire va bene molto bene il
dell'arte digitale è entrato nel mercato
ormai l'arte digitale si colleziona e la
storia dell'arte vedrà l'arte digitale
come il tassello diciamo del prossimo
secolo questo è vero solo in parte
perché in effetti arte digitale non sono
la stessa cosa l'arte digitale in realtà
nasce negli anni 60 e
implica diverse modalità di creatività
perché in realtà la n ft è un asset
tecnofinanza ario cioè la ft non può
esistere senza la block cei quindi un
collezionista che compra un n effetti
anche se in alcuni casi ormai ci sono
gallerie che li vendono ii iii danno non
in cripto valute ma con carte di credito
normali in realtà ha bisogno della block
chain per esistere e quindi in realtà è
molto chiaro che quell'oggetto creativo
quell'opera d'arte esiste perché esiste
questa diciamo piattaforma digitale che
è legata alle critto valute e qui
bisogna fare un attimo un passo indietro
perché diciamo negli articoli
nella vulgata sembra quasi che
finalmente grazie alle cripto valute
l'arte digitale ha avuto accesso
all'olimpo dell'arte è stata pagata una
cifra importante è stata comprata per
ogni tanto viene da farsi l'altra
domanda è che i grandi investitori in
tutto valute hanno capito che
comprando opere d'arte in cripto valute
comprandole a cifre importanti era
l'arte che è un asset socialmente
riconosciuto che è conservato nei musei
che scrive la storia dell'umanità a
rendere vere le cripto valute beh forse
in questa diciamo in questa frenesia per
gli nfp causa effetto ogni tanto sono un
po confusi perché sicuramente se si
pensa al caso di mipel sicuramente c'è
stata una volontà di grandi investitori
in cripto valute a sostenere una vendita
così importante per avere le prime
pagine dei giornali e per rendere le
cripto valute vere infatti dopo questa
vendita l'importante più importanti case
date accettano le cripte decritto valute
sono considerate un asset normale nel
mondo dell'arte questo però non vuol
dire anche se questo mondo diciamo
legato alle cripto valute pone grandi
temi di sicurezza e protezione perché se
tu perdi la tua diciamo password al tuo
wallet al tuo portafoglio digitale in
cui custodisce le tue opere comprate
magari a cifre anche importanti tu non
hai niente non c'è nessun modo nessun
server dove tu puoi andare per
recuperare perso e sulle cronache dei
giornali che l'anno scorso forse il più
importante museo d'arte digitale lo zkm
di karlsruhe in germania ha perso 3
cripto panche in realtà li aveva
comprati a delle cifre insignificanti
per un laboratorio di ricerca
il ricercatore che li stava spostando da
un sito all'altro ha sbagliato url egli
ha bruciati si dice li ha bruciati vuol
dire che in realtà questi cripto punk
sono visibili nel museo degli schermi
online sono visibili sono del museo ma
il museo non li potrà mai vendere perché
non ha più accesso al suo portafoglio
questo ha creato tanto rumore in realtà
per nulla perché come ha detto il
direttore noi di statuto non possiamo
vendere le nostre opere quindi in realtà
forse bruciandola le abbiamo rese
davvero perennemente parte del
patrimonio se tu però non sei un musico
e ha interesse nel tuo scritto vuole
questo tema di come proteggere che come
avere sicurezza restano importanti ma
torniamo un attimo al mondo dell'arte
quindi abbiamo detto questo oggetto che
infinitamente ripetibile mai considerato
unico grazie
alla black jail vengono scambiati per
cifre importanti il mondo dell'arte però
anche se ci sono come dicevo chi grida
alla bolla speculativa lo sta guardando
questo fenomeno i musei stanno
investendo in piattaforme le gallerie
stanno aprendo spazi per creare effetti
e soprattutto gli artisti che poi sono
il motore del mondo dell'arte si stanno
dedicando a indagare questa nuova
tecnologia
pensando al futuro di questi nfp forse
interessante guardare anche un po
un'esperienza passata quando sono nati
il mondo del cinema e della fotografia
il mondo dell'arte gridava al disastro
se si pensa a un testo così importante
come l'opera d'arte
all'epoca della sua riproducibilità di
walter benyamin del 35 viene predetta
alla fine dell'aurea dell'opera d'arte
noi sappiamo ovviamente questo non è
successo pensando a opere come rhein di
gursky che è stata venduta per 4 milioni
300 mila dollari per le collezioni di un
museo e quindi guardando a questa storia
del passato dobbiamo davvero immaginare
il futuro di questo mondo con
un'apertura mentale e quindi andare
davvero esplorare queste piattaforme e
ognuno nei suoi termini come scopre
l'arte andare a scoprire cos'è questo
mondo degli nfp sicuramente ci vuole
attenzione e bisogna proteggersi dalle
frodi dal fatto che ancora la
regolamentazione in questo mondo legato
alle cripto valute sia in via di
definire sicuramente sarà più facile in
un futuro ma andandosi a buttare in
questo mondo davvero uno può scoprire un
po il futuro dell'arte contemporanea
sul futuro quindi di questa tecnologia
la vera domanda è saremo guidati dagli
speculatori dagli investitori in cripto
valute che sono interessati solo a tra i
dare quindi a fare profitto da questi n
effetti o gli artisti sapranno di nuovo
prendere il centro di questa rivoluzione
creativa e creare opere che spostano
davvero il futuro dell'arte
contemporanea portandoci a scoprire cose
che non riusciamo ancora immaginare beh
io sono convinta che saranno gli artisti
a scrivere il futuro dell'arte
contemporanea grazie